[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right scum and villainy let's make
some noise for kevin smith and mark
bernard batman beyond
[Applause]
welcome back to fat man beyond i'm kevin
smith i'm mark bernard
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
everyone's in such a good [ __ ] mood
man that's crispy
that's really really nice man just
before we get going folks a little uh
fyi just all in all seriousness
um we're gonna put on a show for a
little while up here we may say things
that you don't like
if that's the case if anyone
thinks about [ __ ] stepping up here
and trying to slap either of us
i will tell you right now
i will burst into [ __ ] tears man i
will
i will cower and offer to suck your dick
in exchange for not hitting me and my
friend so
unless you want to be subject to that
everyone stay in your [ __ ] seats
would you please
how are you
but i put that out there i appreciate it
i appreciate you doing the lord's work
uh i'm i'm fine thank you can i
tell you a share a story i used that
same [ __ ] joke i went to um uh
where'd i go uh okay wondercon thank you
i went to wondercon on friday it's
wondercom weekend everybody go to
wondercon this weekend
cons are back for three people um
it was absolutely wonderful wondercon of
course uh hosted by the good folks that
host uh comic-con international as well
aka the san diego comic-con
i was invited down as a guest
you know i go to all the cons but
sometimes they actually
want you to go to the con and stuff is
that like it's nice it's very sweet yeah
they're like we'll fly you down i'm like
to anaheim uh
i was like i flew down myself
um drove down
got up on stage did like an hour q and a
on friday night
smooth as silk had a good time uh at the
very end somebody asked about bruce
willis i got very emotional you probably
found it online and stuff
uh
went home felt really good
about the whole thing
then that that night or the night after
i guess it was la the night after
i noticed that the san diego comic-con
put up a tweet
on their account there's a photo of me
from being on stage
and this is the text
that they included with the photo okay
from day one of wondercon 2022 kevin
smith gave us his salesman pitch
to sell wondercon on kevin smith as a
person
podcaster pop culture commentator writer
director and general nuisance
now like doesn't that like i i'm not
being as like [ __ ] sensitive doesn't
that occur to you as like like a weird
like hey man i mean hey it's poorly
written
i mean that's a shitty truth
you ain't [ __ ] kidding man
but also like why are you gonna invite
somebody into your house
and then call them a nuisance once
they're inside thank you which was my
point when i wrote back to the account i
retweeted this and i said um general
nuisance what the [ __ ] i answered
questions for an hour i didn't pitch or
sell anything weird post to make about
an invited guest
and you know it got liked by a lot of
people uh almost 4 000 people jumped to
my [ __ ] defense
most of them being like [ __ ] you san
diego comic-con like how do you do this
to kev like that and [ __ ] like that and
i was like yeah [ __ ] whoever wrote that
[ __ ] tweet and [ __ ]
then i started rereading the tweet over
and over and the syntax seemed damned
familiar
so i went and looked
at the actual
website for the con
with the description of the panel
and the description of the panel it was
called the panel with kevin smith
the world's worst kevin smith salesman
tries to sell you on kevin smith as a
person
podcaster pop culture commentator writer
director and general nuisance
whoever [ __ ] wrote the entry for the
catalog wrote that and the tweet was
quoting
that entry in the catalog so it wasn't
the person who wrote the tweet who was
being an [ __ ] whoever wrote the
description in the [ __ ] wondercon
catalog
is the [ __ ] and when i looked at it
for a few minutes i said oh wait i wrote
this
[Applause]
so i uh
for the second time this week i issued a
twitter apology of sorts and uh
and i wrote mystery solved the weirdly
specific tweet copy was a reference to
the panel description from the wondercon
website and do you know who wrote that
panel description in the first place old
general nuisance himself me
apologies to the comic-con twitter for
being a total stoner um
that's not much of a stoner i am mark
sometimes i forget the [ __ ] i write
about myself and i'm like why i oughta
i feel like you're gonna get demoted
from general nuisance to like corporal
news yes after that you can't be trusted
they should really strip my rank but
even worse than all that is you said it
was poorly written [ __ ]
wow
could he use a semicolon or two in there
i just feel like a walking [ __ ] uh
meme of of uh what was that [ __ ] was
dj khaled when he was like
congratulations you played yourself
so strange how are you that was uh
wondercon still i think it ends today it
ends today uh so you know if you're in
anaheim like right now rush over and
stuff like that but still be here yeah
it was a wonderful event and i thank
them for having me out they're probably
not going to invite me to the san diego
comic con or if they do they're like we
will write the copy this time we got you
on this um how are you what have you
been doing this weekend i'm good i'm
good i was also at wondercon on friday
you went to wondercon too i did what'd
you do there how did we not cross paths
well i i i was early and you were late
story of my life yeah like i had a panel
at uh 3 p.m to talk about my my comic
book adora in the distance
[Applause]
uh currently on sale from dark horse
comics and comixology um but so that
panel was from three to four and before
that i was just walking the floor like i
hadn't been on a proper comic convention
floor in
three or four years what is it like for
you to walk on the floor do people
recognize you and be like holy [ __ ] one
out of every 20 people are like just you
you're not quite sure what the intention
is just you you didn't you didn't like
the batman did you like well
i got like three or four of those what
was your problem with the batman's like
i talked about that for now or on the
podcast
that's good that you saw because you
know i had a problem with the batman um
that's an easily like uh they could
point to you be like you're that guy
that doesn't like blank
well we'll see if we can prove that out
later today
yeah we got some [ __ ] to talk about you
might have seen some things we i think
we both have seen some things i
definitely saw a thing
how's your neck all right my neck my
looks like i got some blood sucked out
of the side of it
let's let's jump to it because uh a
thousand people asked me on twitter like
when i started saying we're doing the
show on sunday
they're like you guys gonna talk about
morbius
and i was you know i wanted to write
back like that would mean we'd have to
see morbius and i
i doubt we're you know i'll eventually
see it at home i watch everything by the
time it comes home and [ __ ] so you know
i assumed we'd get to morbius but then i
saw like a shocking tweet
on twitter uh almost complained about
that as well turns out it was written by
you and you were like i went to see
morbius
i did how the [ __ ] did that happen well
it happened because i
i i am lucky enough to have a couple of
teenagers in my house one of whom is the
busiest teenager in the world who i
rarely get to see as much as i'd like to
like he's you know swim practice in this
and he's doing lifeguard training in
like high school all that [ __ ] and so i
haven't been with the kid for longer
than like half an hour for almost two
weeks right
and so i'm like you know what [ __ ] it
let's go see a movie what's in the
movies and morbius is legit like the
only thing in the theater near us right
so let's go see more beers and my son's
like really
yeah how bad could it be
[Applause]
i'm glad my dad never abused me like
that
and here's the thing
it's bad
like i was like hey you're that guy that
didn't like morbius
i was i was describing it to somebody as
you know when frank sinatra and the rat
pack used to make those movies in vegas
back in the day like ocean's 11 and
robin on the seven hoods
they were they were playing all night on
stage at the sands or whatever and then
they'd show up at 11 o'clock in the
morning and shoot like a scene or two of
a movie and then go to sleep and then do
it all over again and they would get so
late in the production schedule those
movies that at one point the director
goes up to frank sinatra it's like hey
frank listen we're like
15 pages behind like we gotta i really
need you guys to show up early tomorrow
i really need you guys to work hard and
so frank goes to the script 15 pages you
say
rip
pulls him out of the script and says
well now we're caught up and so
the movies never really made any sense
they were just done and so morbius is
kind of like that
where they sinatra this [ __ ] they
sinatra this [ __ ] because there's like
the building blocks of a decent movie
are there yeah um it's like three drafts
away from being a pretty good script and
jared leto is [ __ ] he's an
oscar-winning actor like he's not like
he can't do this
fair didn't like it but
like i understand all of the sort of
dramatic pressures of the movie i
understand the character moves i
understand what michael morbius wants i
understand what the bad guy wants i
understand what the sort of a vuncular
caretaker wants like every it's all kind
of there but the worst versions of it
and then tyrese shows up for some reason
and
tyrese
did you know that tyrese built a uh
benihana in his backyard of his house in
sherman oaks like an actual benihana he
used to call it gibsahana
and so you could go to tyrese's house
and like he would [ __ ] get on the
[ __ ] spatulas and hibachi you up some
[ __ ] food wow
that's about how well he acts which is
it's like
it resembles food that you might like
but it isn't really food that you like
like he resembles an actor that you
might enjoy watching in a movie but
rarely is he that person unless it's
legit just a fast and furious movie
where his job is to crack jokes and look
stupid in front of the other people who
are supposed to look smarter right like
he's the guy who makes the rock look
super smart
he's the guy who makes vin diesel look
like a genius because it's tyrese
and so
but tyrese is trying to be a tough guy
and that's not his speed and tyrese also
apparently has a robot arm in this movie
that you only see in the very last scene
when he's like he rolls up his sleeve
and it's like wait is your arm made of
metal
done credits they don't they
nothing they don't explain
it's a movie that that defies
explanation or almost a return except
that it's got two cut scenes i mean i'm
sorry two post credit scenes right to
set up like this sinister six maybe
with michael keaton obviously in one of
them and not at all in the other one
even though the vultures there
that don't connect at all to the movie
you just watched they don't make any
sense at all with anything you've what
you've seen it's it's mystifying in so
many ways but it's not awful
it's just bad it's lazy in a weird way
right
so like
listen i've seen much worse movies
um we've all seen much worse movies but
if you were like
really desperate for air conditioning
and you had to stumble into some theater
you could do worse this was a and it's
also short
what did your son say afterwards um he
didn't he was he wasn't as kind as i was
to you or the movie he's like that was
awful dad that was the worst movie like
and it's not even it should have been
funnier for as bad as it was and it
wasn't
i'm like wow that's harsh was there any
mcu stuff was there spider-man stuff um
there's there's one sequence when
morbius is walking down a street and you
see a picture of spider-man that says
murderer on it that was on the internet
that's in the movie i it was in one of
the trailers i'm not sure if it made the
cut and then one of the post-credit
sequences is all about the uh the
multiverse thing it's you see the big
crack in the sky and then adrian tombs
appears in a prison cell in this
universe in the morbius universe like
he's been sucked from one world into
another and so i was like hey i'm this
is cool i'll be here now and that's the
the extent of the michael keaton of it
all and then there's another scene with
with the vulture full masked up and
everything so it's clearly not michael
keaton there's just michael getting's
voice
encountering morbius in the desert
they're like we can do some [ __ ]
together and morbis is like yeah let's
let's do some good
question mark and then the rest of the
credits and then i left
whoa
it's not good you guys
of of the marvel things that i saw this
weekend that started with the letter m
it was clearly the worst of them
it uh it did decent box office though i
made 39 million dollars over the weekend
and and then more overseas because it
opened yeah like 80 something million
overseas like it's it's going to do fine
it's not going to be a hit it's not
going to be spider-man but
is this one of those movies that he did
extreme things to get ready for
uh i mean he's in he's in like marvel
shape he's in the shape that you get in
when you have to take off your shirt in
one scene that sounds extreme to me
which is relatively extreme but it's not
like the machinist right it's not when
he lost 150 pounds to look like
that um yeah he's uh known to commit in
a big bad way
saw a lot of people on twitter being
like can you imagine committing that
hard for a movie with like
18 on rotten tomatoes or something like
that
i was like yes i can imagine that
says mr yoga hosers
um well nobody sets out to make a bad
movie you know they wanted to do
something you know they wanted to do
some good just like at the end of the
movie to do some good yeah and they were
really just like a couple of left center
right away from it being decent um but
they got they got lost in the fog bank
of ambition
uh i saw that today on the internet that
he is 50 years old
jared leto 50 50. i'm 51. yeah that's
what i said
i'm [ __ ] 51 and he's 50 and i'm like
that's possible the [ __ ] am i doing
wrong um
very old man yeah no so is but don't
look it
idris elba also 50 the rock also like
51. that might believe because they're
tall
he sees him why this
wispy little guy they got wisdom why
does height equate to not only age i
don't
know where he's older he's like an oak
yes the taller you are the wiser you are
i guess i don't know
um but yeah
he's wispy i saw him in real life when i
went to like the suicide
squad premiere
attractive man
jordan catalano yeah i mean very well
moisturized
that's that's
is that you know who else is insanely
well moisturized take a look at him next
time you're around him jason muse really
yeah i think he [ __ ] bathes in oil of
olay or some said [ __ ]
he's got like rich moist skin and one is
it's adorable lately and then the other
day he was over at my house and he was
talking to me and he had this [ __ ]
thing he's going yeah i thought he was
like electric shaving his face i was
like what is that he's like it's to keep
me young yeah
he's exfoliating yes like right in front
of me i was like stop exfoliating around
yeah do that private
um all right well mark uh you know saw
morbius give it up for mark for taking
the bullet period
somebody had to
um
i'm sure uh before we dive into the news
we have a sponsor don't we we've got a
pair of sponsors my friend oh [ __ ] first
up first stop let's talk about the good
folks at chili sleep
chilly sleep chilly sleep all right uh
what's the website let's send people
there i'll tell them what what what
you're supposed to do head over to
chilisleep.com fat man to earn more to
learn more and save 30 off the purchase
of any cube or uhler sleep system it's a
thing you put beneath your sheets that
keeps you cool oh i have once they sent
me they sent us this to try out this is
actually badass i actually went through
the trouble of doing my first my wife
was just like what the [ __ ] now and i
was like hold on hold on because she's
always getting like [ __ ] hot we're of
a certain age mark so obviously we heat
up in the night and [ __ ] like that put
this on the bed man she actually liked
it it's still on the [ __ ] bed yeah
science tells us that the best way to
achieve and maintain consistent deep
sleep is by lowering core body
temperature temperature controlled sleep
repairs muscle after a hard day's work
and improves cognitive function so you
always start your day feeling sharp and
alert well except when i wrote that
tweet but other than that yes very sharp
and alert you know who really [ __ ]
loved it
you know we got shecky the doctrine
she's uh 17 years old man she's all
sugar snouted out and [ __ ] old as [ __ ]
but you never know it she's spry still
[ __ ] zips around the house and [ __ ]
she sleeps with us and uh we i wish we
would sleep in a roman numeral three
pattern
like i sleep this way jen sleeps this
way and i wish the dog who always
insists on sleeping between us in this
like no-touching kind of way
wish she would sleep in the same
direction but she does the h instead so
she sleeps like with her ass up against
me and her nose up against chin and this
[ __ ] heats up it's like sleeping
with a three-bar heater and [ __ ] all
night long that [ __ ] cooling pad
saved my made the dog tolerable for the
first time i sleep with two big-eared
german [ __ ] mark and the uh
and they're both they're as hot as
cylons remember when the [ __ ] cylons
would have sex and the spines would like
glow red and [ __ ] and i was like how
does guys baltard not noticed that man
like you think it's you big man so i
think uh the cooling pad has been a real
help hopefully they appreciate my
endorsement i i bet you they will
they're like did you say chilly [ __ ]
big here german [ __ ] chilly sleep
makes the uhler and cube sleep systems
hydropower temperature controlled
mattress toppers that fit over your
existing mattress to provide your ideal
sleep temperature they keep your bed at
the perfect temperature yeah temperature
for deep sleep whether you sleep hot or
cold uh imagine waking up and not
feeling tired chilly sleep can make that
happen so head on over to chilisleep.com
fat man to learn more and save 30 off
the purchase of any new cube or euler
sleep system that offer is available
exclusively for fat man beyond listeners
and only for a limited time that's c h i
l i sleep dot com slash fat man to take
advantage of our exclusive discount and
wake up refreshed every day we thank the
good folks at chili chili sleep chili
sleep chilly sleep man i can legit vouch
for this it sounds complicated but it's
not it lays out real [ __ ] easy and
it's easier than that
give it up for the good folks at chili
sleep sponsoring fat man beyonce thank
you chilly sleepers
[Applause]
that's one of the things we never really
talk about the unspoken benefit of doing
this show is like when we do ads they
have to send us the things we do ads for
so we get to [ __ ] with everything and
whatnot for free [ __ ] you would never
really [ __ ] with like would you ever go
out and chilly sleep it of your own
accord i didn't even know it existed and
it showed up and now like it changed my
kingdom for a chilly sleep exactly now i
can't travel without it and i'm about to
travel i'm heading away this week man
i'm going uh
uh east um to new york uh it's jen's
birthday so we're going to new york and
then this weekend um going to philly for
the fan expo nice i'll be there on
saturday with jason muse and
brown o'hara jeff anderson trevor
fuhrman all the folks from clerks um so
i can't bring the chili sleep with me
it's gonna be [ __ ] up sleeping in
random hotels just lying awake being
like i can't chilly
sleep go get some ice yeah phone ice on
the bed and [ __ ]
um all right we got news uh we got some
news um
we can talk we can we can get into it
however you'd like
we could talk about moon night which i
feel like we need to talk about moon
night let's talk about moon night moon
night made me so happy yeah let's start
there uh how many people saw moon night
[Applause]
boy talk about [ __ ] brand awareness
what a well-trained [ __ ] audience we
are
marvel's like here it is and we [ __ ]
launched to it like right away that's
more people than i imagined i thought
like oh i hadn't caught up to it yet uh
a show of hands how many people haven't
watched moon knight yet
when i say showhand put them together
uh we're gonna spoil it a bit but
there's no real [ __ ] spoilers other
than what you've seen in the trailers i
would say yeah the trailers are mostly
taken from the first episode very much
so um so
you know
for for a guy who's been reading comics
for years and years and years just the
idea that they ever got to moon night
was like what are you [ __ ] insane
then you saw the trailer then they cast
azerite oscar isaac then we saw the
trailer everything lined up like
insanely sweetly um it looked like it
had a kind of seven approach to it you
know in terms of the dual personalities
of uh mark spector and uh steven grant
um i i had high hopes for this [ __ ]
thing and it cleared the bar like all
the [ __ ] way in such a way that as i
was watching it i was like i'm just a
mark for this [ __ ] man i don't even know
if i could properly review
a marvel anything because it really does
feel like they're engineered to hit all
of my [ __ ] pleasure zones so much so
that i can't even see [ __ ]
flaws um i mean look i saw that the
eternals was long don't get me wrong
um long was the problem with it oh yeah
like yeah
sometimes like but the this like
every step of the way i was watching
moon night i was like god damn it man
this is [ __ ] god i can't believe it
takes my breath away that they're even
[ __ ] doing moon night
can't believe they're pulling it off as
well as they did um and then you know
you get one of the greatest actors on
the planet
to
to play your your main character um and
throw on the effects all of it
was fantastic to me i watched it with my
wife she's been i've been forcing her to
watch all the marvel stuff i started
forcing her but then she's gamely in uh
she was just like i don't know what the
[ __ ] going on i was like i do and it's
[ __ ] amazing you know
that [ __ ] the last few
minutes of the episode when he's trapped
in the bathroom
and mark spector finally talks to steven
grant
that was everything that i wanted in
that show like i was waiting for it and
i know they have to build it up and
start a narrative and [ __ ] but i was
like just get to the moment where they
could start communicating and he could
just be like give me the power give me
the power and it's such a great scene
where he's like so [ __ ] calm in the
mirror and he's like stephen i can save
us
oh i [ __ ] loved it so much man and
finally like stephen gives control
and you see the [ __ ] bandages you
know that make up his outfits start
coming together
bam this [ __ ] like what an anubis dog
monster yeah something like that he's
[ __ ] coming through and like leaps
on him before he can even [ __ ] change
man and that's when like they cut
outside the bathroom [ __ ] sink goes
flying then you see that [ __ ] dog
trying to get the [ __ ] out of there and
[ __ ] and he drags back in and that's the
shot from the
teaser and the trailer of that where
everybody loves from behind pushing in
on moon knight while he just beats the
[ __ ] living [ __ ] out of this thing
first time i saw that trailer i was like
this [ __ ] [ __ ] so he's just beating a
dude but he's beating a big dog so it's
okay and [ __ ] so he's just beating the
[ __ ] out of this thing and then gets up
walks toward us like right into a
close-up you see the full outfit credits
i was like
perfection man like [ __ ] perfect
first [ __ ] episode i absolutely
loved it i can't wait to see [ __ ]
more uh my only complaint is like you
know [ __ ] disney plus is just like
first taste is free come back next week
but you know
i wish they put all the episodes up but
still i'm here for it every week nothing
wrong with being taught to anticipate a
thing as well so i i can't wait you
[Applause]
well i'll tell you kev
uh i've had some issues with with marvel
tv shows in the past
um and my issue is is it has been
sometimes i don't know what
how i would come to these shows if i
didn't know everything about it already
you know i felt that way a bit about
hawkeye i felt that way a bit about um
loki you know i'm bringing especially
one division i'm bringing so much to the
table as a fan yeah that that and i'm
doing so much of the work of this show
operating on any frequency that i'm
understanding brilliance that's the
brilliance of their [ __ ] operation is
you're right you have to do so much i
know but i've also started to to lament
the fact
that
that
they can be a little lazy relying on me
to do that much effort
what i loved about moon knight is that
it's brand new it is not connected to
anything we've ever seen before in the
mcu as far as the viewer of this
particular cinematic universe is
concerned there's no runway for moon
knight right there's no there's no real
runway it's not like oh he showed up
first and then sequence of [ __ ]
events if you're a reader then yeah you
know the the history of
moon knight you know werewolf by nights
we started you know all the various
permutations of it you know some of the
writers who've written it and you have a
sense of the the dissociative identity
disorder at the center of the character
but if you're not that familiar you're
coming to this cold and i love the fact
that this was a show that treated an
audience as if they needed this
information to understand it and it
rooted all that in character rooted all
that and oscar isaac and i'm not sure if
it would be as successful if it wasn't
oscar isaac agreed he's magic because
he's doing i mean
all of the accent stuff is so much fun
to watch and he is a sort of bubbling
idiot gift shopist he's got like a
british chris reeve thing going on yeah
like it's a bit that it's a bit like
nutty professor it's
um it's a bit jekyll and hyde which is
how i sort of explain it to my wife who
was as confused as yours was like is he
dreaming what's happening here i'm like
i don't know it's all he's it's a
multiple person that's like oh that's
cool like yeah it's [ __ ] cool i'd
have been like i don't know if he's
dreaming but i am this is a dream come
true shut the [ __ ] up
but i i i was on board i went for the
ride i loved i loved the action when it
kicked in i loved i love you [ __ ]
like it i [ __ ] loved it man oh [ __ ] i
thought you were getting ready to [ __ ]
on it mark liked it he liked it
see what happens
i can recognize a good feeling like we
just passed you a bowl of life and you
started eating it and [ __ ]
he likes it it is [ __ ] dope right
it's super dope oh my god i was it took
my breath away and then i was like i'm a
mark though the low the bar is low for
me i [ __ ] love everything marvel and
[ __ ] it's so nice to hear you who's
always put things through like a
you know a [ __ ] closer finder than i
ever do uh say that you dig it and for
those reasons as well there they did
[ __ ] build that whole claw yeah
they're doing all of the work and
they're they're establishing a tone and
a mood and a character who we feel for
because you know how sad his [ __ ]
life is [ __ ] cry i can't believe i
can't believe you liked it too
i'm not alone we're here yes you're
finally it took [ __ ] 400 episodes but
we're here
on the wings of love only the two of us
truly together flying high truly bad um
yeah i mean
and i loved ethan hawk even though i
don't really know
how his cult works right like because
cults have to have an upside right like
nobody just shows up to get randomly
killed like well what are the benefits
what are the perks what do you get out
of me signing up like do i get cool
sneakers is that what we're doing here
right are we here for like the barbecues
i'm not sure but i love the intro that
character walking on the the broken
glass sandals you know here's a dude
who's all about pain and all about
judgment
um who
and i just love the the bit that got me
laughing the most was when he's
explaining to to stephen about that he's
you know he's the avatar for for amit
he's like avatar oh like the blue
kittens yeah it's like oh no like the
anime it's like oh deep [ __ ] cuts
thank you marvel um but yeah i'll watch
oscar isaac do anything i'll watch and i
and i love these action scenes that were
super dissociative like you don't know
where you are coming in or going out
they were very cleverly shot yeah
because you're they bring him
you're always in stephen's perspective
you're always in his pov and because he
doesn't know what happened then we don't
know what happened we just see the
fallout of it
and and i love that there's
like marvel is is trying to
build this version of the universe that
can exist within the disney ecosystem
right like we've i don't know about you
guys but when i signed on to to uh to
access moonlight it started asking me if
i wanted to set my my viewership level
it did that as well for me you know it's
like we're tv 14 do you want to go tvma
do you wanna how restrictive do you want
it to be
and i love that like moon knight has a
scene where where stephen is driving a
cupcake truck
filled with corpses
down the barreling [ __ ] alps of what
maybe is latveria perhaps
and
yeah
oh my god
oh i just came so hard
that could be right
there were dudes online who would they
looked at like the castle at the top of
the hill and
matched it with comic book castles on
the top of hills
this makes it a thousand times better
oh my god i'm such an easy mark yeah but
just dead bodies surrounded by cupcakes
feels like what this is being inside the
disney ecosystem which is
we're gonna be a little grisly here
we're gonna like there's blood on this
dude's hands for real yeah but over
there is a cartoon mouse and over there
is a dancing lamp and we're gonna be
fine with it
makes sense they're bringing they i mean
they brought in they made a big deal
about bringing in the netflix shows
and you know those daredevil alone
punisher alone are two you know yeah
very bloody very violent shows i'm not
saying that like in a bad way i'm saying
like they have to move their
their ratings bar how high can you put
it up can you put like i want full
frontal nudity moon night
i want to see oscar isaac's dick
and they're like we don't have that
setting i'm like well i ain't paying
this month
because netflix does
[Music]
i'll go see scenes of a marriage please
[Music]
um i don't think you have the oscars
dick setting but
they do have a tvma which gets you all
of the netflix stuff is that right yeah
so that you got to click it in order to
get there you know and it'll probably
get you the deadpool stuff at some point
when that shows up because they're
making a deadpool 3 and it's inside the
disney fox
bubble like and it's i don't think
they're going to tame it down because if
that's the brand um so they're gonna go
disney after dark
mickey's penthouse yeah
where the mouse gets the cheese
um yeah man if you haven't seen it yet
uh [ __ ] moon night episode one is up
just episode one but it's it's a hearty
meal it was like 40 minutes or something
yeah no it was a legit episode and we'll
get another one on wednesday and we'll
get i think it's six episodes total and
when that wraps up we'll be in [ __ ]
kenobi land and everybody wins and then
after kenobi's done dr strange will be
out
and then we can all die
no what's after that there's something
to live for i mean there's gotta be
another marvel's thing cause ms marvel
is coming yeah she-hulk is coming yeah
secret invasion is coming oh yeah
[ __ ] scrolls that's worth living for
it's all coming man uh what about in the
movie theaters what's after doctor
strange um
i don't know
no it's um love and thunder
[ __ ]
that's definitely worth [ __ ] sticking
around for all right so we got some cool
[ __ ] we got some cool [ __ ] i watched uh
something else
oh banff man is here give it up for the
bar owner ladies and gentlemen
it's bamf man himself jc
did uh did you guys see all the press
around oscar isaac being like oh yeah i
signed on to just do the show
like you know like
chris evans signed on to do 8 million
movies and hemsworth did it signed on to
do
uh oscar isaac was like oh no i'm doing
this six episode show so they don't own
him so they he might not he doesn't have
to come back as moon night
so this could be
the end of moon night at the end of the
show or
it could be the beginning banff man
let's not go negative like i would like
to think after these six
if they're like hey man we want to bring
you into the event what's he going to
say no like i mean i think that he's
part of his press tour has also been i'm
excited to bring moon knight like i want
to see what like mark specter is next to
[ __ ] thor next to the guardians like
how this
how this character weaves in
to the to the mcu proper now this just
means he'll have to pay him
which is i didn't sign a seven picture
deal like i signed a one series deal you
want more of this cheese
you got a nibble [ __ ]
they're like why are the metaphors all
mixed
they're all about cheese
um yeah i i don't know if that means
like he won't stick around but uh
are you saying that that means he could
potentially play somebody else in the
marvel universe i mean no it just means
that we better enjoy what we get because
we might not get any more oscar isaac
i'm gonna see that glass is half full
this is the beginning of something
beautiful not not something limited what
are they gonna kill him at the end i
mean it's also like this is are they
gonna kill him at the end jc
he's because if they are and you know
something please tell me i'm enjoying
the program
uh i mean he's a star wars franchise guy
he's an x-men franchise guy
he's wow he's done a lot of franchise
movies that's true that's a good point
he was in the dune he was in dune yeah
and he [ __ ] well spoilers didn't make
it out of dune alive now
[Applause]
you almost saw his dick though that's
true yeah you did see him a lot and
almost totally naked in that movie yeah
god he's such a great actor man shy
elude
um i watched uh last night um it's on
amazon it's called outlaws
it's a new steven merchant comedy really
absolutely [ __ ] adorable uh totally
well done very uh ted lasso and the
funny and feel good but uh has some
drama to it kind of way
um absolutely good watch the drop out is
almost over that has been a phenomenal
[ __ ] watch
um are you watching we worked
i'm not i haven't watched any of these
like ripped from the headlines slash
podcast i have i'm forced to watch all
the documentaries with my wife so when
they dramatize them she's like here we
go round two
and then we can compare like oh that's
that person oh that's that person and
[ __ ] that's what you do when you've been
married for like two [ __ ] decades you
stop [ __ ] and you're like let's
compare [ __ ] documentaries to
remakes of the documentaries that'll be
sexy oh so sweet um i watched that what
else about [ __ ] launched
we talked about winning time right that
you're not watching it because you don't
care about basketball
oh that's the lakers yeah yeah i haven't
watched it hey you did you enjoy it yeah
i mean it's it is it is by turns like
really excellently done
and maddening because if you know
anything about where the story is going
you're just waiting for them to get
there it feels a bit like an exercise in
taffy pulling where you're like i know
that's pat riley he's eventually going
to be the [ __ ] coach and i know that
guy's not going to be the coach and yeah
like [ __ ] magic is 100 gonna lead
this offense and so they're they're
doing these things where and yeah it's
historical and i get it but as a viewer
you just want to get there
and we are taking a long time to get
there and like yeah no it's an
interesting road trip and i get it and
i'm liking what i'm seeing and the
actors who play magic and kareem are
phenomenal
but i just like show me show me the
lakers that i want to see show me the
lakers i know we're going to get
um so yeah i'm enjoying it but
no lancy
did you see uh
coda
not yet dakota um won the best picture
best picture best uh adapted screenplay
and best supporting actor yeah i mean
honestly it looks like my speed i've
been in love with
marley matlin since children of a lesser
god
uh deeply in love with her as an actress
uh this uh so it's shocking that i've
been watching this yet kevin yeah
it's the movie you have to watch this
[ __ ] movie and when you say i have to
you just i mean everyone should
everybody should but you have to why why
because
i i i is full frontal oscar isaac's
nudity in it
i i i have been known to shed a tear in
a movie or two it's one of those
man when i tell you there's a scene in
this movie that broke me in half really
and like the kind of crying that you
can't control
where like your face is doing [ __ ] and
you're like i see it but why can't i
stop my lip from shaking and then my the
cheeks are blubbering and there's water
all over my face
kind man
dude
i love it when a movie tear jerks me off
just [ __ ] it
i can't help but like
the lip quivers
i mean i was i was like moist through
most of it but there's one [ __ ] scene
that holy [ __ ] man like it's worth the
trip alone that it wasn't the oscars you
just [ __ ] this is you just now i know
what i'm doing tonight i'm absolutely
watching this when i get home you should
get jen like no there's no [ __ ]
superheroes in this one except for like
people who are super because this family
is amazing who is the actor who won best
or do you want better troy
who's uh who's a actor or supporting
what did he get supporting best
supporting actor his speech broke me uh
at the oscars when he talked about
i think he was talked about his father
was the best signer he ever knew and
then he got in an accident so he was
like crippled from the neck down he
couldn't move his arms anymore and that
was such a
heartbreaking [ __ ] thought of like
your only immune means of communication
to express yourself and even that's been
taken from you oh that destroyed
no it does and and the movie is if you
don't know what it is it's about
uh a coda a child of deaf adults who can
hear
and that is an acronym that's an acronym
and i thought it was coda like the end
of a story or something like that it is
also a little bit of that uh double
meaning as it goes it's one of them
smart movies
oh [ __ ] well i got you thinking it must
have been a nice change after morbius
but yeah so she wait coda is child of
deaf adults wow so she can hear and
speak and she loves to sing and has no
idea if she's any good because the only
people she would sing in front of are in
her own house and everybody's deaf
and so she wants to join the choir
because it makes her feel good when she
sings
but
her family's never heard it and so it's
about can she and she's a senior in high
school and she should go to college does
she have talent can she maybe pursue a
career in music and her family has no
idea if she can or not i'm about to cry
now like that's
how beautiful it's gorgeous i mean it's
it's not dissimilar to movies about
for example like immigrant families
where here's the young kid who can speak
english but then the family who can't
right who like it's the child caught
between two worlds what's your favorite
immigrant movie
um
jesus coming to america
[Applause]
answer the night right there i'm not
even gonna answer now
[ __ ]
anyway
you should 100 watch coda it's beautiful
i get why it won all the things that it
won
um
you know and was definitely a bright
spot in a otherwise uneventful oscars
yeah
it's so weird that uh more people aren't
talking about i mean quest loved one
he did he did [ __ ] summer of soul was
on my top ten
beautiful yes a friend of mine is a
producer on it as well uh david
dinnerstein who i've been working with
for years and stuff his first oscar too
um yeah what else uh one that
that did have you checked out anything
that one that you hadn't checked out
before like coda you hadn't seen koda
before the awards i saw koda the
saturday before the sunday of the awards
i'm like i'm going to watch one [ __ ]
oscar movie and then so you wanted to
like going like i hope this [ __ ] i
went in just [ __ ] caping for it and
i'm glad it won i was i was this is
gonna have like this is no judgment
on the oscars or anything but i was
sleeping i hiked running and i came home
and i was tired and i went to sleep and
you know the oscars happens like [ __ ]
right down the street from our house at
the
it used to be the kodak what's it now
dolby dolby the dolby theater it's in
dubli and dub it's in total doubly
somebody gave him a
sock and he was free and suddenly we
could go watch the thing so it's it's
always like
you know uh wonderful for everybody in
the oscars kind of a hassle if you live
in the neighborhood and so i tend to
stay
up in the hills or over in the valley at
that point so i came home from the
runyon hike and i was like [ __ ] old
man sleepy so i just laid on the bed and
went to sleep and [ __ ] and
you know it happens early out here
um so it was happening while i was
sleeping
and
i was like out cold man me and shecky
and you know there was no gen so we
couldn't make an h
so she was sleeping in the in the right
way and [ __ ] just right next to me and
lulled by her breathing and [ __ ] and i
was out and then suddenly [ __ ] my
wife
turns on the lights
and [ __ ] like stomps on the bed and
she's like you have to get up
something just happened on the oscars
and i was like man i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm sleeping man i'm not gonna watch the
tweets or whatever the [ __ ] and she's
going no it involves two people that
you've worked with and i was like man i
don't work with anybody that ever goes
to the oscars man
you're out of your mind and she's like
chris rock got hit and i was like what
and that woke me the [ __ ] up right there
and i looked at [ __ ] twitter and i
was like oh heavens uh
were you watching the ceremony uh i was
i was a little bit tape delayed at home
not by the broadcast but just by me
because it's like well [ __ ] it i'll
pause it like who gives a [ __ ] i'll i'll
make my way through
one of the worst versions of the oscars
i've ever seen and you're like look man
they can wait i'm taking a [ __ ]
what's the rush yes and then you know
while you're taking the [ __ ] suddenly
twitter blows up and people are like
have you seen the [ __ ] oscars i'm
like yeah i guess dune won another
[ __ ] craft award and costuming or
whatever dude didn't really get to give
a speech because [ __ ] oscars i was
like no
[ __ ] will smith smacked chris rock in
the face
like for real everyone's silent like
they're like what you just did you
didn't know this right i mean
spoilers if not
um yeah weird night yeah
that's all we got to say about that yeah
that's it right there
leave it right there i've cena
seen a lot of people talking about
subject that it's like
you have no business talking about it
daniel radcliffe harry potter himself
had the most magical response the whole
thing he was on some morning show and
they were like uh hey man what do you
think of the [ __ ] slap
and he was just like you know i'm just
so dreadfully bored by all of it
there's some words to that effect or
some says [ __ ] so he was like i'm not
gonna give you my opinion because this
whole thing's [ __ ] boring like right
on man
harry potter [ __ ] yeah i mean which
he's like i put that [ __ ] in the pensive
i don't even know
yeah talk to me in 30 years i'll let you
know what i remember truly yeah i i
similarly don't have very much to add to
what has been a week's worth of
discourse and hot takes and
cancellations and all of that other than
to say
that careful
gently
we we don't know very much about either
of these two men's lives and the things
the paths they've walked that got them
to that particular stage on that
particular night
much has been said uh by
by many people including will smith
himself about his own
lifelong trajectory which he outlined
in detail in his recent biography
um
you know chris rock has also been in the
public eye for a very long time and
revealed apparently struggles with with
sort of
adhd and
and some neuro atypicality
non-visual
disorder yeah he's bad at non-veg
non-visual cues or non-verbal cues or
whatever non-verbal that's a non-verbal
learning disorder um which means roughly
that
yes he's he's not as adept at picking up
social cues which a lot of people have
like praised him for
bringing attention
to that at this particular moment in
time yeah i mean all i'll say is that
that chris rock said he's not going to
press charges
will smith has apologized he's he's
resigned from the academy you know
they're not going to take his oscar away
because that would then open the [ __ ]
cupboard into all of the other
[ __ ] who's off so we would have
to take away and have it yet yeah
um
and so ultimately rock way way for a lot
of horrible [ __ ]
um so rock will say his side of the
story at some point you know will will
probably continue to make apologies and
say he's going to work on himself and
hopefully that's all genuine
but it could be one of the most watched
episodes of red table talk ever i'll
tell you that obviously
yeah and and i do think that
words themselves are a kind of violence
and
and i know this because there are some
words that if somebody called me that
word they might catch hands for that
and i feel like
we do live in a [ __ ] around and find out
society and it seems a little bit
pearl clutchy
to not
extend that to the somebody might have
[ __ ] around and then somebody might
have found out
um
but
and i also don't think that we would
give a [ __ ] if this wasn't on the oscars
yeah um if this was at a 7-eleven if
this was in a nightclub if this was
anyplace else in the world but in front
of
millions of people and more importantly
for this case millions of white people
wouldn't be wouldn't blink an eye
so
that's all i have to say like
they're going gonna find ways to work it
out they'll
either make progress or won't they'll
improve or they won't um they will both
continue working you know like will
smith there's been a couple of slow
downs on projects he was working on
there was a fast and loose movie he was
gonna do a netflix that they put a pause
on there was another bad boys movie that
they put a pause on it won't last for
long because he is
he remains one of the few movie stars we
have left
and so at some point he will get to work
again on the other side of whatever this
is um
but i don't know if there's much more
for us to say
about a thing that has nothing to do
with us other than having been
spectators of a weird-ass night on one
of the worst
telecasts of the oscars i've ever seen
they was shitty before we got to which
is saying a lot because last year was
tough last year was tough they held in
the train station but pretended it
wasn't a train station
yeah i mean they keep trying to pretend
that the oscars are not a show that
people will watch if there's a movie
that they love that's been nominated and
they will not give a [ __ ] if there
wasn't and so when a movie like titanic
or lord of the rings or
or [ __ ] dark knight return dark
knight are up for oscars they will get
higher viewership than when drive my car
is up for oscars or coda which nobody's
seen
like almost like there's another movie
that could have been nominated that
wasn't yeah like it's as if they they
broadened the the bracket for how many
movies could be nominated from five to
ten to make room for potentially the
more popular you know what before we go
any further and [ __ ] but give it up for
mark's very eloquent take on the
situation
very thoughtful response uh and a
perspective uh that i have not seen yet
um but i'm gonna wade into this
discussion
and
and give you my thoughts and
it's a bit controversial but you know
what i work in this business too
i'm a member of the academy so i get to
say whatever the [ __ ] i want here's my
take on it
spider-man definitely could have been
one of the 10 films
nominated for best picture there i said
it you did it
you [ __ ] did it man
i wasn't sure you would but you [ __ ]
did i found the balls
huevos grandes
vamp man's back everybody the other
thing that happened that nobody's
talking about because it wasn't part of
the show is sam jackson got a lifetime
achievement
which didn't denzel washington presented
to him as well
how the [ __ ] is and all i saw was one
picture on twitter like
did that happen like instead of seeing
that on the actual oscars we got to
watch wanda sykes take a tour of the
oscar museum
what the [ __ ]
like you're gonna have denzel washington
giving sam jackson a [ __ ] honorary
oscar we don't get to see it
denzel you've been hoodwinked
you've been bamboozled
you've been horn swaddled
um he uh he was uh the unintentional
star of the night
washington
yes
uh for being apparently the gandhi of
fisticuffs
the other big beneficiary of the night
was [ __ ] g.i jane man this is a movie
that nobody has [ __ ] thought about
that
in over two decades and [ __ ] i guarantee
you a bunch of people jumping on google
going is that a real thing
is that a doll no
um so yes that that that i feel like is
probably all we need to say about the
oscars yeah done and done uh what else
we got newswise
well you know what one more thing to say
about the oscars is still in win all
right moving on all right moving on
um bruce willis oh [ __ ]
um
yeah i know um
bruce willis the 67 year old star of die
hard armageddon and pulp fiction is
stepping away from acting as a result of
health issues chief among them is
aphasia
a condition that according to the mayo
clinic robs you the ability to
communicate it can affect your ability
to speak write and understand language
with verbal and written it is often
caused by a head injury or a stroke or
potentially complications from covid
it's uh particularly cruel because this
uh robs you of your ability to
communicate and uh that's what bruce has
been doing for the better part of
what 40 years plus now at this point
he's in
the communications arts
as an actor as a singer
and has enjoyed
a lifetime doing that he got to make his
living
by expressing himself and
aphasia robs you of that this is very
cruel very very heartbreaking um
i dropped a tweet of course the moment i
read about this i talked about the other
night
at wondercon i'm going to try to get
through it without getting as emotional
because a lot of people you know [ __ ]
give me [ __ ] about crying and everything
and whatnot but i'm a 51 year old stoner
so everything touches me
uh
i have my issues uh obviously
during the time of a cop out and uh
and uh at a certain point like i wasn't
shy about talking about word got out and
stuff and
um
you know it's been 12 years but i
definitely
talked [ __ ]
about uh bruce um
and
when i read the news the other morning
like
all that [ __ ] went away all my so-called
complaints everything that i ever
thought i mean to be fair it's been over
[ __ ] 10 years a lot of that stuff
just went away anyway and i have
interacted with bruce over the years
since then
um
but that really
uh wrecked me man it took me right back
to my childhood to the fact that like
long before i worked with bruce willis
i was a massive bruce willis fan
watching moonlighting every episode of
moonlighting with my mom as she fell
asleep on the couch i stayed way too
wide awake because
i loved david addison
wanted to be david addison when i grew
up like i wanted to be bill murray or
bugs bunny
most clever person in the room was also
human if you ever watch episodes of
moonlighting he's very funny
but uh where he became a movie star or
an actor worth watching
as far as i was concerned was in the
dramatic moments of that show it's tough
to find episodes of moonlighting now if
you got him on dvd you know hard media
you can watch it but
he has some really [ __ ] wonderful
dramatic work in that series you know
they had an on-again off-again kind of
relationship him and uh maddie hayes the
character played by civil shepherd but
he had wonderful stuff
with episodes uh paul cervino played his
father and he's got this great
performance bruce willis in that episode
about his dad
um
that was the [ __ ] i fell in love with
long before you know i [ __ ] went to
see die hard
one night at the middletown movie
theater and
and as promised by the poster got blown
out the back of the movie theater you
know [ __ ] there he was david addison
had become a movie star and he brought
this [ __ ] weird villain with them who
i was like who's the other guy that
guy's great too
um i thought about how much i
loved bruce
before long before i ever worked with
them and
you know
i felt like [ __ ] as i put up on the
tweet like all just felt like an [ __ ]
all that [ __ ] seemed petty now
um especially when i read the
family talking about is a diagnosis so i
felt bad i put up that tweet
i got a phone call
from a friend of mine a good friend of
mine mark cullen
robbie and mark cullen wrote
a couple of dicks a movie that became
cop
uh we had to change the title
because uh
warner brothers had reached out to nbc
they were hosting the oscars that year
not the oscars the
olympics
and so they were like we want to run an
ad in the eight o'clock hour for a movie
called a couple of dicks will you do it
and in 2009 2010 whatever it was we made
the flick nbc was like we will never
run an ad for a movie called a couple of
dicks in the 8 o'clock hour and so that
made warner brothers change style like
you can't use that title you have to use
something we could advertise we
eventually wound up with the title
cop-out
um could you imagine in this day and age
though
any network turning away [ __ ] money
[Music]
for anything like i'm sure nbc if we ask
them today be like not only can you say
a couple of dicks you could show a
couple of dicks
because nobody's watching anymore dude
the [ __ ] you want man we need you i have
dollars and [ __ ] so
we changed the title of the movie and uh
you know went out there as
as cop out and um
the collins were were my bruce
whisperers on set they were closer to
bruce's age and
and uh
and um
it's gonna sound weird but they were big
tall like bruce like older taller you
know i got a thing about older and
heightened [ __ ]
so
um they would be the go-between
sometimes when when uh
bruce and i didn't communicate well with
one another or something like that which
wasn't always the case there were some
days on that show which were absolutely
lovely i remember there's a walk and
talk we do
where him and tracy are talking over one
another and tracy's dressed in this
giant cell phone suits right before
kevin pollock and adam brody come in and
meet them
and it was uh
bruce was so engaged and delighted by
that because he was like this is a
moonlighting walk and talk i was like
absolutely man that's where i stole it
and he was just so [ __ ] happy that uh
you know some days we'd butt heads
though and that's when the collins would
kind of you know like we'll talk to
bruce and stuff
so
um
mark
who i hadn't spoken to in like a year or
two at this point
called me up and he was like uh kev i
saw your tweet
and i wanted to talk to you
and i was like oh man like for some
reason i just went negative with it i
was like he's going to tell me something
that's going to
hurt me even more like make me feel even
[ __ ] worse
um and it wasn't it wasn't negative it
was actually quite beautiful but it did
make me feel [ __ ] worse
um he was telling me he's like i read
your tweet and he's going
i don't i don't want you to beat
yourself up because i know something you
don't know and that's why i wanted to
call you and talk to you and i said
what's up and he's like a couple months
ago
i went out to lunch with bruce mark had
had a falling out with bruce as well
over a later movie that they made
together called once upon a time in
venice
um
bruce reached out to him a couple months
back and they went to lunch
and bruce i guess told him
about the aphasia the diagnosis and and
uh
and talked about like how it affected
making of the movie together and stuff
and he said uh that bruce he goes i know
you think like bruce hated cop out kevin
but he
he said the exact opposite he said like
hanging out with you and robbie meaning
mark and robbie
on cop out joking around with some of
the most fun that i had in the latter
half of my career
and i was like well that's nice to hear
and then mark goes and then he said even
kevin
and i was like all right mark's just
being nice
but i didn't call mark
mark called me you know what i'm saying
like
and i don't i always think of mark as a
pretty
like
honest guy
so he was just like uh
he's
he said that like even kevin and i was
like come on mark and he goes no he said
that he felt bad about
that
time
because he knew that you tried and
this is what [ __ ] really got me he
goes um
uh bruce
said that he liked you
and that's when i kind of broke down
because the whole time i was making the
flick
legit that's the only thing i wanted
like i didn't get paid to make that
movie a lot of people were like warner
brothers you must have got a payday i
was actually the lowest amount of money
i was ever paid to make a movie in my
professional career and that includes
mall rats going back to the beginning of
my career so i never did it for the
money i did it because i grew up
absolutely loving bruce willis i got to
work with him on live free or die hard
and we had a [ __ ] blast and [ __ ]
um
so when the gig came my way first it
came my way as
a couple of dicks and the cast was
will ferrell and marky mark
then
they left because warner brothers wanted
to do it as a pg-13 movie not an r rated
movie
and so will and marky mark went across
the street made a deal to make the other
guys
which was
not i'm not similar but also a buddy cop
movie of sorts taking on the genre so
the project like was going to fall apart
but then jeff robinoff who ran the
studio was like
if you want to be involved still i think
i could still put this together with
other cast so i said oh yeah okay i'll
stick around and he called me like a
week later and he goes what do you think
about bruce willis and i was like
[ __ ] bruce willis i love bruce willis
i worked with i've been watching him my
whole life i just worked him on live
free or die hard it's like we're
thinking about him for jimmy and i was
like oh and then two days later they
talked about tracy and i was like i
[ __ ] love tracy i worked with tracy
on jane's on bob strike back and then
our cast came together and i'll never
forget um one of the first conversations
i had with bruce who again i had met
on live free or die hard and i'd shot
like
behind the scenes [ __ ] for the dvds the
blu-rays with them and stuff like that
but in regards to a couple of dicks i
remember being on the phone with them
and uh it was before i went out to new
york before i saw him
on set and [ __ ]
and he was like you ready to do this and
i said yeah and he's going we're going
to be the yankees and i was like i don't
understand baseball metaphors
and he goes you know hockey i said yeah
he goes we're going to beat a phil
philadelphia flyers the year they won
the cups and i was like all right that i
understand thank you
um and you know and then i went there
and things went a little south and stuff
but you get older and you just realize
that like
that [ __ ] don't matter it hasn't
mattered in [ __ ] years but when i
read that news it mattered even less and
some people like you know you don't have
to apologize you felt the way you felt
at the time but i'm
like why not apologize like what does it
[ __ ] hurt like
what am i holding on to like i haven't
even [ __ ] felt bad or mad about this
[ __ ] in years anyway
and in retrospect like
you know [ __ ]
perhaps
this goes that far back we don't know
you don't know how far it goes back like
i saw a story the other day going like
they started noticing something on
um glass and that was a couple years
back and stuff so
yeah it was a tough i was on wondercon
stage and it was all pretty raunched and
and the other night i started like
crying about that [ __ ] mercifully i kept
it together
uh today for this but
i
this is horrible it's really just
horrible i know a lot of recently he's
been making a lot of movies like in four
or five six movies a year or something
like that
now you can start connecting the dots
and going like this is a guy who's
putting together a [ __ ] chunk of
change
because he's heading in a direction
where he's not going to earn again now a
lot of people out there
you know i see people online all the
time going like why would this person do
this movie why would this person
do this commercial don't they have
enough money or something like that
um
the simple fact of the matter is
probably not
like you know you make that money spend
that money like the lifestyle
they live bruce owned i think an island
at one point
you know that's expensive so the money
comes in the money goes out it's not
like you're sitting like king cretius
with a worse scrooge mcduck with a pile
of [ __ ] cash somewhere comes in goes
out and so i guess if we don't know for
a fact but from outside the situation
with the information we have known we
now have
it could be
seen as a guy who is like i have this
much time
to
not only
put together this much like work to
pay for my health care in the future or
something like that but but more
importantly i got this much time to do
the [ __ ] thing that like defined me
the thing that like all i ever wanted to
do in life was like
act and [ __ ] sing like i had the
[ __ ] return of bruno on cassette on
record on cd it's still
even years after cop out it's still on
my [ __ ] apple music like ernie
o'donnell who runs smog castle back home
he taught me to drive he's a few years
older than me and stuff
cassette player in ernie's car had
[ __ ] the return of bruno smashed in
it and it wouldn't come out so the only
[ __ ] thing we could ever listen to
but we didn't give a [ __ ] because we
[ __ ] loved it so much man so
yeah it was
it was a tough uh thing for me to
to read and it ain't about me i mean
it it made me feel a bunch of things and
and i feel like i grew up just a little
bit you
you think you know a situation man you
think like you could be like go to my
grave [ __ ] these are the facts and i
know this to be this and thus to be true
and then
one piece of missing information
yes everything you believed about that
into shadow where you're like
maybe you didn't know [ __ ]
you know maybe this was going back as as
far as then you couldn't see it like now
i've been sitting here for like days
just trying to remember like
were there signs and i was just too like
oh he's mean to read it as anything but
that i don't know but
in any event man i saw a lot of people
online on twitter going like bruce is
the goat greatest of all time and stuff
like that and you know i honestly hadn't
felt
that way in a long time and it felt
really good to be able to be like he is
isn't he the greatest of all time like
rather than holding the [ __ ] grudge
for over a decade
it was just nice to kind of be like
yeah i love bruce willis i always did
anyway
uh he's not gone he's still with us and
mark said something about like you want
to come see see him with me if we get a
chance and i was like i would absolutely
love that
um
but uh
it's it's not going to be an easy road
ahead
um so let's raise it up for bruce man
yippee kaye [ __ ]
[Applause]
is that all the news we got no we got a
couple more things oh [ __ ]
uh
ezra miller
oh my god
are we sure he's not playing reverse
flash
because he's always [ __ ] hitting
somebody he is
allegedly an [ __ ]
[Laughter]
he's well [ __ ] put out there
allegedly allegedly
two hawaii residents have filed for a
temporary restraining order against
justice league star ezra miller claiming
that the actor harassed and threatened
them the complaint claims that miller
burst into the bedroom of the
petitioners and threatened the alleged
male victim by saying i will bury you
and your [ __ ] wife
and he said this to the person who owned
the house yes
did the person who owned the house shoot
back keep my
wife's name out your [ __ ] mouth
you were so good that's that's a legit
thing i think that's a legit thing
that's a legit complaint i got a wife
you got a wife you know yeah
according to court records obtained by
the associated press miller is accused
of stealing some of the alleged victims
personal belongings including a wallet
and a passport
the respondent is famous and wealthy the
document says this makes assets to
access to weapons much easier as well as
sending associates to harass the
petitioner
because the actor has allegedly been
staying at the couple's hostel in hawaii
this comes after
apparently maybe the same [ __ ] day
march 28th when he was arrested in a
hawaiian karaoke bar
for disorderly conduct and harassment
according to a facebook post shared by
the hawaii police department officers
determined that the 29 year old miller
became agitated with people at the bar
who were enjoying their karaoke session
miller began yelling obscenities and at
one point grabbed the microphone from a
23 year old woman singing karaoke and
later lunged at a 32 year old man
playing darts
also the crimes of grindelwald opening
next week
yes right
and this is the flash that we get
great greg
is just [ __ ] sitting there
the only only bad thing on grant
gustin's rap sheet he smoked a little
vape in a plane once remember that
like they caught him like smoking a vape
in the plane and he was so embarrassed
and [ __ ] like that this flash beats the
[ __ ] out of everybody
allegedly
beats the [ __ ] out of everything yeah
i just i will never understand that
decision for the life of me which is and
we've talked about it before in the
podcast
grant gustin's been the flash at this
point for 48 years
and
in those 48 years warner brothers has
spent
billions of dollars marketing him as the
flash on television hundreds of millions
of people have seen him in that costume
and for them he's the [ __ ] flash
and so to not take all of that goodwill
all of that money spent all that effort
put forth and just bring it over there
to the [ __ ] movies and now you have a
built-in guy that people are wanting to
like
and now we're going to do ezra miller
because he is excited
i guess
he's on he's allegedly excited
um is the uh academy looking into his
background as well
i mean that's that sounds [ __ ] way
worse than anything
bamf banff man's here be careful when
does flash come out like could they
all the money in the world him
with grant and like
i'm sure look anything's possible but
they're not even talking about it is
there's that one shot in the trailer
where isn't he dead center super girls
behind him but then another version of
him is in the shot as well i thought it
was three flashes but it's a supergirl i
believe the one is the super girl no
yeah i think it's supergirl ezra miller
flash up front and then what looks like
another ezra miller flash am i incorrect
anybody else see the same image
so if that's the case you'd have to get
rid of so many ezra millers you know
like in order [ __ ] to uh christopher
plummer out of this movie and at this
point flash entering the speed force is
the most popular movie moment of the
last hundred years according to the
oscars
and that happened like that was like
supposed to be the big moment of the
oscars this year like all the the
internet was like here it comes they
[ __ ] we the the snyder verse folks
were like we got it we got the big
moment and it was overshadowed by
something i forget what happened but um
yeah they did get their mom they don't
get an award though do they it's just
like a highlight or something i guess i
saw a lot of people say like they won an
oscar flash won an oscar i was like i
don't know i didn't get that they get
the participant participation trophy
version the oscars
i would take that
um did you agree with the you know five
[ __ ] most cheerworthy moments in
movie history
no
like
at all
because like it's either gonna be this
movie or it's gonna be all movies and
then all movies like the matrix bullet
time like but it's still matrix bullets
that's cool yeah that's cool but but and
also back when it happened i'm sure we
were all like wow i don't even know if
we cheered in the audience i think we
were more like this is [ __ ] nuts i
mean if anything like
if anything besides end game and the
portal sequence is that moment then i
called [ __ ] him catching that
[ __ ] hammer is honestly one of the
loudest moments i've ever heard in a
movie theater in my life you know how
they say if you [ __ ] go to a hockey
game
at the mad house where the blackhawks
play when they do the [ __ ] like uh oh
sake
was that song again national national
anthem
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
apparently uh
smoke that one away the uh
when they do the national anthem that's
scratch fever yeah it's that one
it is so thunderously loud when they get
to the land of the free like everyone
goes ah and it's it's one of the loudest
uh moment like recordings of human
beings on the planet or something like
that that was what happened
in the [ __ ] premiere
i went to the premiere where the famous
people go where nobody ever likes the
movie if you love movies never go to a
[ __ ] premiere they all sit there
quietly because everyone there has
worked on it and like we hate this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
but i went to a [ __ ] premiere where
even the [ __ ] like like chris
hemsworth that was his date for [ __ ]
endgame i was one of his plus one i mean
his wife was there don't get me wrong
but i was on his list and [ __ ]
he went nuts and i'm like surely he knew
it was coming like
right next to me he's like i knew it and
then on screen he was like i knew it
um yeah it was
the dream girls moment threw me i don't
remember that being a big thing either i
mean
i i love that song it's very stirring
sure i'm also telling you i'm not going
but i don't remember everybody [ __ ]
shouting at the rafters
when
effie gets her moment
um what about in star wars was there
there's a collective gasp moment where
he's like i am your father spoilers i am
your father
um but
i'm so sorry
but is there like a whoa
i mean yeah you were all clear-cut oh
you know when the [ __ ] go home which
one we're all clear kid let's blow this
thing and go home
i'll tell you the biggest [ __ ] cheer
moment in star wars that they've
delivered in recent memory is luke's
young luke skywalker and the mandalorian
when that [ __ ] x-wing shows up and
you're like who is this you see the
green blade and you're like holy [ __ ] if
that was in a movie theater that would
have like blown the [ __ ] roof off
well vader in rogue one yes that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh my god
because we were in the premiere and that
premiere lost its [ __ ] mind yeah i
remember [ __ ] who was it chris
hardwick was sitting in front of me when
that moment happened and he reached back
and grabbed my leg
and i knew exactly what he meant i was
like [ __ ] yeah clutch it this is [ __ ]
up
god yeah that's that could have been
there that could have been one of the
moments yeah nope
flashing does this mean
allegedly
um all right what else we got all right
i'm sorry somebody put a harry potter
book up there who's that for
who's signing it me
sign the harry potter
okay what's the story there
[Music]
but also you just had a harry potter
book lying around
no significance just the only thing i
had on hand
i thought it was some sort of statement
like yeah we're the new jk rowling and
[ __ ]
um okay uh what else we got after you're
done
is that your first harry potter book
you've ever spent it is yeah
yeah oh wait hold on
did you write magically delicious mark
bernardin
[Music]
no take your time it's only a two-hour
show what the [ __ ]
[Music]
oh that's good
yeah it was worth the time he wrote
trans rights matters on the book well
done
all right what other news we will we
will end with
the crow
that's all they're gonna make one
they're finally making another crow
movie a reboot i imagine not a deep
sequel to the story of eric draven yeah
yeah yeah but bill skarsgard he was
pennywise the clown amongst other things
is now going to be playing the tortured
rock star who comes back from the dead
to exact his revenge i love that jimmy
bar book from back in the day it's a
comic i bought off the rack man such a
book really yeah you still have it oh
i think it was one god the books in my
collection that i sold to make clerks so
[ __ ] the crow helped me get there but
i remember like i loved the movie i
thought they did a really good job
um especially all things considered you
know the accident that happened while
they were making the movie they're still
able to pull a decent flick out of it
but i look forward to this man it's a
cool concept
yeah um he's a good actor he is a very
good actor nice guy yeah he's a nice guy
i interviewed him a real nice guy tall
as [ __ ]
real pretty brother holy [ __ ]
that's all i could talk to him about i
was like i would [ __ ] your brother's
senses
like man or not he's beautiful that
vampire
but yeah the dude who made um well
snow white and huntsman and ghost in the
shell is going to direct
rupert sanders
snow white and hump the huntsman and the
live-action scarlett johansson ghost
ghost in the show was that i mean this
is telling tales of school was that the
director that like she
didn't in that she was making that snow
white moving she was with rob pattinson
but then she kissed the director
that's the guy that's the guy
wow
did you see she wore shorts to the
oscars
i did that gave me hope right there
maybe one day i could go to the oscars
with my shorts well i'll tell you like
you got good legs
so she i'm just but i'm saying like
yeah you're putting me on par with it no
i'm giving you that you were raising one
to lower another
we're both pretty good your legs are
fine but
you got good legs man you can totally
rock some shorts thank you [ __ ]
that's first you liked [ __ ] moon moon
night and now you tell me i got nice
legs see am i dying why is this the
greatest show ever for me
i mean you play your cards right yes
there is a green room after the show
um all right was that all the news
that's all the news mark gave you the
news give it up for mark you gave me to
do
[Applause]
um
quick quick news uh they moved obi-wan
obi-wan was supposed to open on may 25th
they moved it to friday
the 25th to start with that may 25th is
the star wars release day yes and they
moved it to the 27th friday and they're
gonna drop two episodes instead of the
first one oh all right well we have to
wait two days before that we get another
episode yes all right fair enough man
hurt me like that all over again
um when is that may 22 may 27th can't
[ __ ] wait man
um
all right we are uh we have another
sponsor we do indeed sir our second
sponsor of the evening ladies and
gentlemen is an old favorite ours man
the people we love who make a smell
[ __ ] good nice job thank you very
much it could have been one of three i
know i was like [ __ ] it who is it
uh give it up for the good folks at
native ladies and gentlemen native.com
what address do we send them to
uh if you're gonna follow along at home
man that's nativedeo.com
fat man where you're gonna find all
sorts of information you hear us talk
about native all the time my wife
legitimately came in to my office the
other day is how long we've been married
we struggle to find [ __ ] to talk to each
other about she came into my office with
this [ __ ] thing a native this uh
deodorant she goes
it's no longer plastic they got it in a
cardboard packaging ooh and i was like
oh god remember when we used to [ __ ] did
that sound genuine
why are we talking about this old lady
[ __ ] old man [ __ ]
uh but yes she was very impressed by the
[ __ ] packaging man um i love
the native products they smell so
[ __ ] good they're tasty don't eat
them but they are vegan and [ __ ] tell
them what they wrote this week
native is doing their part to help our
earth with their new 100 plastic free
and recyclable packaging like the man
just said
when you buy natives new plastic free
recycled package deodorant you're saving
37 grams of plastic native is also a
proud partner of one percent for the
planet and are committing one percent of
their plastic free deodorant sales to
environmental nonprofits [ __ ] night
and this is important i just read a
story this week says we eat like a
credit card's worth of plastic every
year or something
yeah
wait is that they're not not the right
response to that no no
death like it's all these micro plastics
that like wound up in not just the food
wheat but like salt sea salt so when
you're like oh i got some of that pure
sea salt it's got [ __ ] micro plastics
in it over the course of a year
apparently we eat like a credit card
where the plastic goes into our guts and
it doesn't do good things so
i'm not saying like these guys are
saving the world but they're trying
could i use like the power of will to
summon that credit card to buy me [ __ ]
which will are we talking about here
well uh absolutely man you could totally
just run your hand over a reader and
change it see that's the move because no
without that mark you can neither buy
nor sell i don't know if you knew that
or not
it's biblical folks yes
oh sweet cane
natives like don't talk about religion
during the ad we're selling [ __ ]
deodorant man
with native shoes from 10 cents
including their classic coconut vanilla
sensitive formulas that are formulated
without man they needed a comma there
that are formulated without baking soda
even on [ __ ] mr bernardin your
english teacher because i'm i'm rolling
i'm expecting more
of the classic [ __ ] scents in the
like including the classic coconut and
vanilla and
one more thing one more thing would be
cool um but they also have unscented in
case you just want to not stink but
don't smell good so ready to try plastic
free deodorant go to native
nativedeo.com
fat man or use promo code fat man at
checkout and get 20 off your first order
that's nativedeo.com
fat man or use promo code famine at
checkout for 20 off your first order
listen to what the man says man give it
up for native ladies and gentlemen
we thank the good folks at native for
sponsoring uh this here part of fat man
beyond and whatnot my wife legitimately
uses that product she'll buy that
product if they don't send it to us free
and [ __ ] that's how much she likes it so
a vote for native is not just a vote for
[ __ ] fat man beyond but a vote for
are you signing all the books that's
clever i am yeah that's a good idea
i learned from you dad
[Applause]
where's is where's nate
uh no nate today no
posters donate the greats let me check
on nate man
we well he sent artwork today where is
it
like yeah up here oh but like not
printed or worse yeah
so i think he's okay i hope so [ __ ]
uh he may not be here right now but give
it up for the dark nate returns he did
some wonderful moon night art this week
and he did
um yeah look at that [ __ ] mention
this is abbott and costello oh if my old
man was alive he would have thought that
was hysterical he would be like finally
i made it
um all right
this is the part of the show where we do
q a ladies and gentlemen and apparently
we got some fine fine gifts to give out
for the people who get to ask questions
our good friend deacon who works over at
uh 40x and screen x has given us tickets
to give out so whoever asks a question
whoever gets picked by jc is gonna get
two tickets
uh to go watch a movie in 40x and you
want to watch a movie in these vibrating
chairs you will not ladies and gentlemen
and you're going to win that and you're
also going to win a copy of mark's comic
man
a dark horse book there's a [ __ ] 15
value right here two of those tickets is
like [ __ ] 50 bucks right there giving
that [ __ ] away and then apparently we
have these
empire of blood
that was uh weird heavy weird vibe on
twitter i guess talk found you on runyon
one day yes and talk to you about giving
these out tonight absolutely and so
to everybody here uh to the question
people it's a question people we have
two of those to get gas expensive book
man
right on all right so there's a
raft of prizes ladies there are indeed
you're gonna walk away with some [ __ ]
and if i haven't sold morbius to you
guys well enough
it's playing in 4dx and screenx there
you go so like
if you want to get
your soul sucked
right out of your pants
go see morbius
have you ever wanted to sleep through a
40x screening kids
it's it's the best way to see morbias
because every time you
shakes you awake
get up get up he's about to do a thing
i believe uh dr strange will be in 4dx
screenout
as will fantastic beasts
and the
crimes of ezra allegedly miller
what this is the one with where they go
back to hogwarts right dumbledore
dumbledore secrets of dumbledore i'm
sorry not the crimes of grindelwald i
[ __ ] that up but now it's hot gay
young dumbledore
doing cool she was played by jude law
i'll watch him do anything right
especially other people at hogwarts and
[ __ ]
so they go back to the school
i think some of it we're gonna see like
young miss mcgonagall and [ __ ] like that
um who's probably the same age as the
other mcgonagall we've seen because
magic
dumbledore gets young and hot and gay
but everyone else's age is uh just the
same i have uh i'm not i'm not throwing
shade i haven't seen any of these
fantastic beasts movies i love the harry
potter movies but this franchise
didn't uh speak to me fair
you i've seen the first one and didn't
care for it very much
never saw the second one but again
if this is finally where this franchise
always should have been with jude law's
magic spy
then [ __ ] i'm here for it yeah
tying it back into the [ __ ] books
that's when i like you have my interest
so this might be the first one that i'm
like ah
um all right jc is usually in charge of
these things so that me and mark
uh can be guilt-free and all this i
gotta tell you man i'll get stoner i'll
just throw this out there i'm having a
good time tonight everyone having a good
time
i was uh
i didn't i wasn't looking forward to
coming because we went out to like a
family brunch and i [ __ ] over ate
vegan food and i'm so stuffed and [ __ ]
like that and i was like man i just want
to lay in bed but i'm so glad i
i came uh i digested and had a good time
at this what did you have for brunch
we went to this place called bach kauri
in um
uh silver lake and it's not all vegan
but there was vegan stuff on the menu i
had a vegan pizza
they had you know i'm a real like
[ __ ] uh
i like hummus but i make my own hummus
you're amish yeah and i'm such i've
become such a hummus snob they like we
ordered hummus and i was just like
acceptable you know
uh but yeah so i felt like all full and
i was like oh man but i've been having
such a good time i don't give a [ __ ]
excellent yeah all right jc
who are we going to go with first uh
napua holgerson
all right
say the name did i pronounce that
anywhere
near right napua holgerson give it up
for dapua everybody
excellent name napua what's that all
about i'm hawaiian and it's a very small
part of a very long name oh what's the
rest of it yeah well yeah francis
napoleon
[ __ ] yeah
on my id it's two lines on my id that's
tremendous yeah it's a little intense
um so in honor of wondercon this weekend
um i love going to conventions and i
always say that everybody has a specific
reason to go to a con like i go for the
panels but people go to cosplay people
go to get autographs people go for
collectibles
so i want you guys to think about your
favorite fandom
or uh
pop culture group avengers
justice league whatever
and take the members of that group and
figure out why they would go to
conventions like tom hall and spider-man
probably goes to collect funko pops
like just take a couple people whether
from whatever show or movie and just
kind of figure out what you guys think
why they would go to a convention fair
enough you want to start
what if how about we how about we we run
dmc it with the avengers
i'll do one you do one i'll do one you
do one okay is that what run dmc is
alternating lyrics peter piper pick
peppers but run rock rhymes that's a
good point um so
i'll start with cap
captain america captain america captain
america goes
to get vintage back issues from when he
was a kid
in brooklyn so he wants to read like
the og [ __ ] timely books that were
published back in the 1930s before he
gets the super soldier serum he wants to
remember what it was like to be a boy
[ __ ] hey they can go to any
convention it doesn't have to just be a
comic-con
wolverine goes to run fairs
just feels at home there man you know
it's a better time he can get the blade
sharpened and [ __ ] like that nice i can
see that happen over to you
um
i feel like thor goes to biker rallies
like sturgis would be thor's [ __ ]
move
um let me see um
i'm gonna go with uh a groot
goes to every weed festival across the
united states
for sure for sure he gets loaded with
free samples too i went to a weed fest
in washington man like i could have
literally opened my own weeds to her
people gave me so much free weed they're
like here try this [ __ ] groot is way
more beloved than me goes to a weed fest
he's walking away with i am high like
good goes to a weed con
over to you
i feel like rocket goes to um
i think he goes to like
porn convention i was going to say
animal rescue
sort of events to break all the animals
out
and let them be free but also porn is
also fine
uh let me thank
conventions
um i'm gonna go with uh
oh professor x is a huge trekkie he goes
to a lot of trek cons and [ __ ]
nobody knows why he just really likes it
particularly next-gen
i i feel like storm would go to like
agricultural fares
and [ __ ] with them making it rain yeah
my man i don't know how to make this
grass grow bring [ __ ]
um and i think johnny storm goes to fire
fest there we're done oh we did
it thank you guys
give it up for the pool everybody she
won some [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
how are you jc uh i'm good i uh my
daughter took her first steps today oh
[ __ ]
[Applause]
it was pretty awesome and i happened to
be
she like went down this little slide we
have in the backyard and i was trying to
get her jen was like try to get her face
going down the slide she's so happy and
she went down the slide
and then stood up and walked over to me
oh my god that's the first time she's
walked
well done everyone give it up for the
kids growing up already so yeah it's a
good day do you remember your kids
walking for the first time uh i do
barely but it's it's it's so weird to
now be at the i'm sure you've also been
there as well
you're now in like the last version of
that instead of the first version of
that yeah it's like it's the last time
this kid will do this it's the last time
this will happen you know i had the the
last time my son fell asleep in my lap
because he was sleepy he was like 14
years old and he just had a [ __ ] day
and like came up for a hug and then just
passed out and i took a picture because
like this is the last time this will
happen all right and it's never happened
since [ __ ] man so yes relish the firsts
my friend this is the last we'll come
first that she takes her first step
today [ __ ] buys a house moves
into laurel canyon tomorrow
and never comes to visit not nearly
enough
not after all you've done for her and
[ __ ] like that
put her in movies and such like anyway
i'm sure your relationship will be
different is her room still her room in
the house
yeah it is but jen is starting to like
take it over and and like turn it into
like a guest room as well but um we've
got a leak in that room that has gotten
progressively worse and i guess it's
because the you know when it barely
rains out here but when it does it comes
down to [ __ ] buckets so the deck
that's outside my office
somehow leaks into the kid's room so jen
like finally got to a place with a room
where she's like i'm gonna paint it and
put up new curtains like it's time to
turn it into something else i'm not
gonna be sad that harley's not here
anymore so she had the whole [ __ ]
place painted and [ __ ] and then the
the roof leak happened and it it's it's
horrendous so you'll watch like the
ceiling blister and then
all the water breaks then you got to cut
it open dry it out because we got that
black mold problem where we live in the
hills so it's always like a [ __ ]
hassle so we fixed it and [ __ ] repainted
it and then a huge storm came [ __ ]
happened again so i was like just leave
it like that man and she's like it's
gonna be the guest room i was like so if
you're staying here for free [ __ ] you
deal with that like [ __ ]
so sooner or later we got to get the
[ __ ] deck fixed and [ __ ] but um it's
it's changing it's no longer
the kids the kid's room now the kids got
her own [ __ ] house
another episode of dad man beyond you
guys
all right jc where are we going next all
right uh
devin chapman
devin devin give it up for devon
everybody
[Applause]
oh man i am better than most not as good
as some [ __ ] hey good answer well
done
uh before we go any further are you
wearing a kilt yes sir i
am thank you thank you
i uh i highly suggest all men wear a
non-bifurcated lower half garment
i uh i you know as a guy who wears jorts
i'm like just a cut away from wearing so
close i know but i'll tell you you can't
wear a hockey jersey with this because
then it just looks like a moo moo it
does the whole thing totally moomoo's
out
i stole a kilt from you know you can
rent them in scotland and [ __ ] the way
you can rent tuxes here so like whenever
that formal event you can rent a kilt
and years ago when i was there for an
event i rented like i was much bigger uh
the largest [ __ ] kilt they had and
some scotsman was like um they don't
make him that big i'm not gonna try to
do the accident he was like they don't
make him that big you should probably
keep that in case you come back and i
was like all right i totally will so i
still have this kilt every once in a
while i put it it's much bigger now just
falls to the floor and [ __ ] but it had a
pin on it
yeah that seems to be a big deal
like you put a [ __ ] pin on it and
then there's that that dead animal you
wear around your dick this morning yeah
yeah yeah yeah this is a utility kilt so
it has pockets and everything it's just
[ __ ] you can put [ __ ] smokes in there
yeah look at that yeah totally one
hundred percent i'm [ __ ] all about it
man i'm gonna start rocking some kilts
you should do the fat man beyond
official kilt i mean yeah but nobody
would know it given that we're
we could be telling people we've been
wearing kilts the whole time yes still
killing
jc is a guy
jc said you guys come out here sam's
pants
sometimes sometimes yeah you can't tell
yeah just [ __ ] bird dog in it the
whole
thing
what do we got for
all right my friends what is the most
obscure reference slash joke you ever
got into a project that no one ever got
oh what a great question
the most obscure joke and or reference i
ever got into a project that nobody that
know what god ever got yeah
i know a good stumper yeah wow
well i've i've managed to sneak a
reference to aliens
in everything that i've ever done
oh really and more often than not nobody
catches it
um
there's always a lv426 as a tail number
for something
frost and bishop were going to be the
name of an of a of a common house in
carnival row
oh jesus um
yeah in splinter the call sign for the
plane is lv426
um just because i [ __ ] love it to
death and
why the hell not there's always like a
spunkmeyer character who like has like
one line just as somebody gets to call
him spunkmeyer and nobody manages to
figure it out but that's that's just my
little thing because i love it so yeah
and only like one or two people like
what is that from like i know that
somewhere it's like do you though do you
do ya do you know what the burke is from
tell me what the burke is from
i think i remember mine
uh in dogma
there's a scene where
it's you know the [ __ ] uh we've
rounded up the [ __ ] heroes and the
bad guys gonna give the villain speech
sequence and they're in the bar
and uh jason lee plays asriel the demon
has uh you know everybody [ __ ] in
chairs and he's walking around telling
the [ __ ] how he was behind everything
and [ __ ] like that
and so uh
you know at a certain point uh
the movie's [ __ ] over two decades old
i think at this point is that correct
yes we passed the 20th anniversary back
in uh
2019. so um
at a certain point
uh silent bob
like there's a driver a cardinals driver
cardinal glick's driver golf driver
that
we find out later was blessed and [ __ ]
silent bob has it i forget why
i think it's over on the table or
something like that yeah it is
and
um jason lee character asriel like uh
tells him
to pick it up like he was like he sees
an interaction between two of the
characters bethany is trying to play by
linda fiorentino he's trying to indicate
to silent bob like get that [ __ ]
driver we'll attack this guy and asriel
sees it and he's like what did you do or
no it's not uh bethany it's a
serendipity who's trying to like inspire
she's the muse character that sama plays
she's trying to inspire sound bob so
azrael catches that he's like what are
you trying to tell him to hit me with
the with the golf club are you serious
i'm a [ __ ] demon you think he's gonna
[ __ ] hurt me with a with a
putter or something like that so he says
uh
um to silent bobby goes go ahead pick it
up
pick it up he goes come on
he goes
hit me and he does a really great
delivery goes uh like hit me
he goes take it
he goes i want you i forget the exact
line but he goes
don't you know and he he goes uh don't
you know anything he goes
god hold on i gotta get the line right
because i stole it from a movie and it
was essentially it's a moment from the
howling
where the character
tells the other character take the gun
and shoot it gives him the [ __ ] gun
he's like come on bret boy come on do it
shoot me and he goes don't you know
anything and then he turns into a
werewolf but the gun had silver bullets
in it and so he takes out the [ __ ]
wolf guy and the wolf is like what the
[ __ ] so in this moment in dogma it's the
same exact moment i just stole it from
the howling he goes pick it up he goes
seriously hit me hit me and he's like no
i'm serious
don't you know anything and then simon
bob hits him in the chest
and since the driver was blessed by the
[ __ ] cardinal it breaks open the
demon's chest all his black [ __ ] runs
out and he's like but i'm a demon
so that joke or reference is directly
stolen from the howling i can't do the
exact
word for word quote now but i stole it
from that moment and nobody ever [ __ ]
knew ever and i waited for some people
to be like oh that's from the [ __ ]
howling and [ __ ] nobody the entire time
it was out there
that's awesome
i mean it was a great question give it
up for devon great question you won
devin pick your prize
[Applause]
well done my friend welcome
thank you uh before we go to the next
one this is a bribe we've talked about
collabing
um but the pen then pandemic you had me
email jordan but no reply so bribe what
is this
who's that who's gave me a jar of weed
in arizona golden lemon grown in arizona
and what do you want to do a collab of
some sort yeah
[ __ ] hey okay
done and done man so wait this is the
contact info here
i'll hit you back
but this is this is the way to a man's
heart ladies and gentlemen
you ever wondering like what does kev
want free weed all the time
it really is
um okay thank you for that okay what is
it let's give it a free ad what's it
called
the comic source
is the name of
of the podcast that you want me to be on
correct
cross over something like that okay so
you're not selling weed you're just
giving me weed to be on your pockets
even better
everyone take a page out of his book you
want me on your podcast
there's no manufacturing involved
distribution i was like business deal
this is great this is easy
i've been on oh [ __ ] did you give you
weed no
i was gonna say can i have it i mean
you're gonna pay me mozzarella sticks
out of taking that but no
talk to matt hawkins for you
yes he did
apparently i'm sorry well done we'll
hook it up thank you for that
allegedly
jc our last third and final question of
the evening uh is from dallas malloy
dallas get up here dally everyone give
it up for dallas oh the big d
fly dallas fly i just gotta say i'm uh
down from canada for the weekend so this
was the highlight of my trip so also
wait a second dallas is from canada yes
this is a true story
shouldn't they have named you calgary or
something like that
uh named after the uh soap opera
actually are you [ __ ] serious that's
a true story your parents were such fans
they're like let's thank god they didn't
love the young and the restless and [ __ ]
like that
i'm told it was a very long labor and
that was like some sort of marathon on
in the hospital room wow that's they
they changed their mind they had uh
everything decided on something else
changed their name changed their mind
that day that is fantastic you were so
close to being falcon crest
[Laughter]
is our son dallas our other son
falconcrest and our other son the 11
o'clock news yes
dynasty would you stop butting your head
against the walls
i don't know why suddenly you sound like
you're from topeka in canada but
fantastic i'm gonna tell my mother about
you i'm gonna be like mom i met a boy
who was named after dallas and she'll be
like j.r i'll be like no legit dallas
soap opera is that where he was
conceived no
not like bryce dallas
is that why her name is bryce dallas i
think all of ron howard's children are
named after where they were conceived
the [ __ ] out of here really
is that real
so the middle name is always like where
they were conceived
so like it could have been bryce in the
bathroom howard yes
wow
yeah okay have you met jimmy backseat oh
it's jimmy yeah
[ __ ] opie who knew anyway over to you
dallas uh thanks um
so recently in the comics news we've
seen a lot of talk about the cyclops
jean grey emma frost uh love triangle
wait for those of us who are not uh
up to breast what's going on the silver
boobs mcgee comment recently no it was
on
really expensive fill us in
they were having lunch in the cafeteria
at the x-mansion and i guess gene and
emma start going at it and they had
angel in the middle and jean's big
comeback was calling emma frost silver
boobs mcgee and
boobs tried to make a whole awkward
moment out of it but so when you say
they were going at it they were fighting
yes sorry
i was like i'm about to read this comic
book forgot who i was talking to sorry
um right on all right so fair enough so
lots of conversations about love
triangles uh what love triangle would
you like to see in any of the media
that's been out there
i'm with you ah [ __ ] it um what would i
like to see
i mean they did well i'm looking forward
to the you know
the x-men being introduced into the mcu
which would give them another chance to
do you know the [ __ ] cyclops
wolverine
jean grey [ __ ] love triangle which
i've always loved not much of a love
triangle right like wolverine loves her
but she loves scott and stuff
um
i don't know if they're doing it on
titans are they doing dick grayson
starfire and barbara gordon at all
i hope so
are they starting to
so him being torn between those two i
thought was always
kind of cool i i don't know if they ever
engineered a story about that but like
those are the two people he's known to
be deeply romantically involved with
um what about you
i i would like to see the
uh steve rogers james buchanan natasha
triangle
and sorry what are the points on that
triangle exactly because that's
a little open i mean
all the points
because
you know
that those two are [ __ ]
and fill in the blanks for who those two
are but they're probably [ __ ] or have
wanted to [ __ ] or did [ __ ] and then
there was ice involved
but yeah i mean peggy peggy's ironically
outside of that love triangle but
there's a lot of action going on
under those
sheets
lucy schroeder charlie brown
[Applause]
because charles like clearly lucy loves
schroeder we all know that but
charlie brown to keep coming back to a
woman who pulls the ball out from under
you each and every time that's love
so clearly he's in love with lucy i
would like to see i mean there's there's
luke
leia han solo
well there was
for a minute like it's text you guys i
don't know what the [ __ ] you're looking
about it's canon it's in there the age
diegem can you imagine the dramatic
irony in a movie that takes place before
a new hope and empire
that has luke
leia and han and every time
luke and leia are about to get it on han
walks into the room and stops and stops
is like whew
because we know but they don't it could
be a mad cap comedy right there
good i got the perfect name for it hand
job
[Music]
people are always asking me like what
star wars movie would you do that one
would feel good for me
yeah not so solo
[Applause]
who's leia who
yeah
um did we answer that question amazingly
yeah because we could keep going we did
i know we really could get one ladies
and gentlemen get them up
excellent job dallas
because there is totally a kirk spock
uhura
love triangle happening
kirk spa in the current version of in
every version of star trek even going
back to roddenberry i mean did spock
like
in the future no but nobody's wearing
shirts every third episode and like kirk
spock slash fiction is real and you add
a horror to that and it's spicy
um wait we had a question we're out of
questions that's it you got anything to
tell these good people
um thank you for coming to your bar yeah
we got uh we're showing the new halo
show the paramount plus
um uh wednesdays as midnight uh
wednesdays at midnight as it turns into
thursdays if anybody wants to come check
out halo right down here this is coming
back in cantina sounds like a [ __ ]
plan doing giveaways and drink specials
and fun stuff like that i came uh the
other night for mark's thing i mean i'm
always here for the show and i rarely
get to come to the bar
um otherwise although i passed the bar
today from on the front
on hollywood for those that don't know
uh scum and villainy cantina is on
hollywood boulevard in hollywood
and i rarely go down
hollywood boulevard just because i
travel over the hill or whatever the
[ __ ] but today we were coming from the
um silver like where we ate and so i
drove past the cantina and i got like
oddly nerded out where i was like that's
this coming villainy cantina
my wife was like where you're going
tonight i was like yes yes i just i
never see it from this side i always see
the the dank back alley this is amazing
so fancy from the front this is it looks
good the building looks like real
[ __ ] good man it's subtle like you
you know you've resisted how many years
you've been in business now uh
five five years yeah three days holy
[ __ ] give it up for dc
[Applause]
five-year anniversary man
i like that
the lady in the audience was like five
before i could even figure out
um it is uh
it was batman's birthday this week
comics 27 was released making it the
first appearance of the batman and the
batman so what anniversary would that be
birthday would that be 53rd
no what what year again 19
39 1939
83. 83 years since the debut of batman
raise a [ __ ] drink for that man holy
[Applause]
[ __ ] truly the reason we all we gather
in his name don't we
he's very tall
[Laughter]
by the age standard he's a giant
um it is it's uh the bar is like real
like you you don't overdo it like i
would have put up like you know [ __ ]
r2d2 heads and [ __ ] like that it's real
subtle it's and jennifer was like what
is that one thing like you know the
thing that's like looks like an antenna
i was like oh yeah that's like a
tattooing robot thing
and uh she was like uh that's it's nice
it's well designed it's really uh who
does jen did the front um the front was
done by my friend elliot at a company
called fanco and the the little
the droid
is has a solar light on it so at night
it'll light up and it was meant to be a
beacon for nerds to come oh that's
adorable
man
how sweet is that
um so yeah man if you're in the area
come down and [ __ ] watch the halo
thing or if you're in the area just
coming to the bar it's a great place to
hang out and drink nobody ever gets
punched in the face and [ __ ] i actually
i have one other thing that i just did
that will happen tomorrow
i took rogers the musical and added it
to our jukebox
so when it comes on the jukebox now
the
the projector screens in the bar show
the video and there's a full light show
that will happen so when they're like
hulk says smash all the lights go like
green dim and then smash and they'll get
like brighter and then so there's going
to be a whole show
like easter egg
into the jukebox for rogers the musical
i mean like [ __ ]
your kid's just learning to walk dude
go home that sounds amazing you put so
much into it uh see you come see
something cool like that right you can
be sitting drinking and all of a sudden
[ __ ] laser light show happens right
here at this coming villainy cantina we
can't do the show uh without them give
it up for the scum and villainy cantina
folks
if uh you're going to be at philly uh
for fan expo uh i will be there on
saturday uh taking pictures of jay
signing stuff um also we put up for sale
uh this week uh jay and salam bob secret
stash
silver anniversary bash this is the 25th
year
of our comic book stores brick and
mortar business and stuff
so we're having this
two
day weekend event uh may 7th and 8th
where brian o'halleran jeff anderson
trevor furman marilyn gigliotti jennifer
uh my wife uh me jason muse
ernie scott schiaffo johnny williams a
bunch of people who were in clarks are
taking pictures with everybody at the
stash and then we're doing a three-way q
a
at the atlantic uh movie house which is
like three theaters and the audience
fill each theater and then the people at
the front
switch every like 45.
yeah it's going to be a [ __ ] good
time so tickets for that are on sale
right now for cease mod at csmod.com uh
tomorrow ladies and gentlemen is also
this just shows you how [ __ ] old and
ancient i am tomorrow is the 25th
anniversary of the release of chasing
amy
came out 25 years ago
so um
we're going to be uh a couple weeks from
now uh april 20th for 4 20 we're doing
movies pop-up again here in hollywood
and uh while we do that i believe we're
going to be doing a
uh event like a q a event with uh jason
lee uh chasing amy's jason lee uh at the
space so i'll i'll let you know as we
get closer check
ceasemod.com for tickets and stuff uh
but yeah where it's time to [ __ ]
celebrate quarterback goddamn century
man so old so many uh
anniversaries you just [ __ ] go like
what that happened [ __ ] seemed like
[ __ ] only yesterday
um
we enjoy doing the show ladies and
gentlemen but there is no show without
the god in my left man give it up for
marvelous martin
and that my friends is fat man beyond
for this week i'm kevin smith i'm mark
bernardin tune in next time same fat
time same fat channel smodcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith jeff's kiss
morbius
later gators
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask kev anything every saga has a 10
year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith